bonjour joël ruet merci de répondre à
notre question sur rt france 50e forum
de davos est ce que ce sommet a toujours
du poids ou est ce que c'est une carte
de visite pour les grands de ce monde
alors d'abord je précise que je suis
venu en train et en effet à pied pour
les temps 10 km écoutez c'est toujours
un endroit influent pourquoi parce que
c'est en fait c'est une caisse de
résonance et une caisse de résonance des
tendances des tendances les meilleurs de
la planète et puis les moins bonnes de
la planète ont pour discuter mais c'est
une caisse de résonance qui réunit les
plus grands acteurs dont vous avez les
plus grands acteurs historiques mais
aussi les plus grands acteurs innovants
et ceux qui sont aussi les plus
influents donc je crois que ça conserve
une importance comme un des rendez-vous
globaux dans cette planète et pas
nécessairement pour changer le monde
c'est pas parce que davos choisi un
thème une année que monde et changer le
long bien sûr
justement vous parlez de deux thèmes il
ya notamment le climat cette année on
sait que des grands patrons notamment de
l'industrie du pétrole et donc longtemps
les
le thème du duc les masses que c'est pas
un peu paradoxal tous a nommé comme je
le disais d'abord davos réunit des
tendances alors chaque année ils ont
choisi ce une ça n'est pas
nécessairement la tendance majoritaire
parmi les entreprises et puis comme je
le disais ils réunissent à des plus
grands acteurs donc à la fois qui vont
dans le bon sens et dans le mauvais sens
mais de même qu'ils ne définissent pas
l'agenda global c'est un lieu de
réflexion des changes influences
mutuelles et d'inspiration d'inspiration
mutuelle et bien de la même manière
c'est pas eux non plus qui définissent
eux ce qui est bon ce qui est mauvais ça
fait longtemps que à davos davos des
acteurs discute d'environnement et bien
aujourd'hui on met ça sur la table
je ne sais pas si ça implique du courage
si ces critiques etc
mais en tout cas c'est l'une des
premières fois qu'on en discute vraiment
et je pense que pour un forum qui
n'avaient pas l'habitude de le faire
c'est aussi le signe qu'il ya un courant
souterrain très fort au sein de
nombreuses entreprises qui elles voient
leur avenir voir la transformation
quelle que soit la constante de temps
que ce soit très court ou plus long mais
elles voient leur avenir dans une
planète qui resterait vivable bien sûr
et vous qui êtes présents à davos
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
le discours compte à l'heure de donald
trump qui a fustigé les néo pro clima
oui non mais donald trump est en
campagne électorale il n'a pas fustiger
les pro clima il a fait semblant de
fustiger les pro climat pour en réalité
fustigé ce qu'il appelle les socialistes
c'est à dire les candidats démocrates
aux états unis qui ont vent le vent le
plus en poupe dont séoul et il ya un
certain d'acteurs politiques qui
viennent à davos pour utiliser ça comme
tribune politique globale ou nationale
c'est pas nouveau
l'essentiel de dabou c'est quand même
les entreprises qui sont entrées sur le
monde réel encore une fois que ce soit
en bien ou en mal quels que soient les
tendances mais se sont élancés
essentiellement des entreprises et
j'allais dire le l'agenda politique
reste quand même minoritaire dans
l'ensemble des débats justement par
rapport à ces débats qui vont durer
jusqu'à quatre jours
qu'est ce qui vous est ce que vous en
attendez qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
concrètement de ce forum de
avos mais je le disais une caisse de
résonance est d'abord une caisse de
résonance à l'extérieur quand davos
alors sur certains thèmes parle de
quelques-uns des sujets ça donne du
poids alors évidemment sur
l'environnement le forum de davos est
plutôt en retard ils sont les derniers à
en parler sur l'industrie 4.0 dans une
précédente édition
c'était plutôt la première fois qu'on a
parlé donc voilà des fois davos est en
retard des fois est en avance mais ça
donne une caisse de résonance un sujet
au niveau mondial mais j'allais dire ça
donne surtout à l'intérieur de la
communauté des affaires ça donne une
caisse de résonance aux gens les plus
vertueux aux entreprises des vertueux
vertueuse pardon qui malgré tout sont là
ont accès à la tribune ont un accès plus
légitime et à la tribune
et de fait la majorité silencieuse les
écoute donc je crois que c'est un des
éléments qui est peut-être aussi autant
important que hocine aussi important que
l'action des ong pour faire avancer et
accélérer le syli sujets
environnementaux
on ne sauvera pas la planète uniquement
avec des entreprises ne sauvera pas la
planète sans les entreprises c'est le
mot de la fin merci joël ruet d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
arte france je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste au cnrs et président du
bridge tanks